bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 13 avril tandis que la voie
diplomatique permettent à oslo une
rencontre russo américaines que nous
relatera patrice randeynes avec
l'analyse de gilles rabin depuis moscou
en macédoine et en albanie les récits de
réfugiés recueillis par valérie fournier
jean bonnie accroissent l'inquiétude
d'une situation intérieure au kosovo
dramatique
confirmation avec le témoignage de notre
envoyé spécial dans quelques secondes
sur place maryse burgot en france les
premiers réfugiés kosovars arrive et à
l'assemblée nationale le pot unis
confirment l'engagement français
l'actualité c'est aussi la publication
d'un premier rapport sur les conditions
d'un incendie du mont blanc qui a fait
au moins 41 morts le 24 mars dernier
l'organisation des secours et la
conception d'une rage sont en cause la
diffusion d'une étude sur la situation
des demandeurs d'emploi de moins de 25
ans 2 sur 3 ne bénéficie pas d'une
indemnité de chômage
et puis l'ouverture ce soir du 23e
printemps de bourges et pour la première
affiche de ce festival de la chanson un
concert aux sonorités égyptienne avec
natacha atlas depuis quelques jours peu
à peu des informations nous parviennent
sur la situation intérieure de la
population albanaise rester au kosovo
divers témoignages qu'il faut bien sûr
vérifier avec prudence évoque des
menaces de famine et le risque d'une
nouvelle vague d'exode massif une équipe
de france 2 avec maryse burgot j
-jacques qui est fait bien brillant a pu
pénétrer à l'intérieur du kosovo nous
sommes en ligne avec vous maryse burgot
vous êtes sur le chemin de retour
vous avez croisé pendant de longues
heures sans nous des réfugiés pouvez
vous nous faire un premier récit de ce
que vous avez pu constater sur place
oui bonsoir nous venons de passer deux
jours au kosovo nous avons atteint le
kosovo en empruntant des chemins de
montagne enneigée et sur notre route
à l'aller comme au retour nous avons
croisé des centaines de réfugiés dans
une situation extrêmement difficile au
kosovo y fait en ce moment froid nous
avons vu des enfants des femmes et des
vieillards affamés égarés et ces gens
dormirons ce soir dans la montagne parce
que le chemin que nous avons parcouru en
à peu près 9
le métro au moins trois jours à le
parcourir ce que je voudrais vous dire
aussi c'est que au kosovo nous avons vu
beaucoup de campements sauvages de
réfugiés ces familles installées sous
des pentes dans la montagne sur la neige
n'ose pas prendre le difficile chemin
qui mène vers le monténégro alors
lamizana vous trouviez dans un village
qui était pendant un instant retenu
potes chez cap il ya eu une avancée de
de l'armée serbe ce s'est passé comment
oui c'est vrai nous étions à guer fort
dans un village du kosovo tenus par
louis ck nous comptions rencontré ce
matin le commandant de nous ces cas pour
la région est né vers 10 heures ce matin
les habitants du gîte du village nous
ont prévenu qu'une offensive serbe était
imminente et les habitants nous ont dit
qu'il fallait fuir
nous avons donc pris la route avec eux
et nous alors ce que nous nous sommes
retournés nous avons vu la plupart des
villages que nous venions de quitter
recouvert d'une épaisse fumée noire
nous entendions des bombardements des
tirs d'armes automatiques
il est il semble évident que derrière
nous les serbes ont bougé la plupart de
ces villages
alors les combats donc continue quel est
l'état des défenses de l'ofce qu'un oui
il est évident que les combats
continuent entre les forces serbes et
les combattants de tous ces cas mais
nous avons rencontrés sur la route de
notre retour cet après midi vers 4
heures nous avons rencontré un groupe de
combattants de l'uck les cas que nous
avons pu interviewer et ses gens nous
ont semblé quand même assez égarés ils
nous ont dit qu'ils ne savaient pas où
il valait et ils nous ont tout de même
donné l'impression d'être des
combattants plus ou moins en déroute
merci maryse et demain nous verrons
portage vous avez réalisé avec gilles
jacquier effet bien brillant donc à
l'intérieur du kosovo
il convient de rappeler les chiffres
fournis par les gouvernements et les
organisations internationales concernées
du nombre de réfugiés dans les pays
proches de la yougoslavie près de 315
milles en albanie plus de 118 mille en
macédoine 63 millions monténégro et plus
de 27000 en bosnie sans compter d'autres
réfugiés dans d'autres pays voisins
la macédoine souhaite
départ de ces réfugiés vers d'autres
pays tout en demandant son adhésion
rapide à l'otan dans les camps de
macédoine nos envoyés spéciaux jérôme ni
andré y sera ont recueilli les
témoignages de ces femmes de ces hommes
venus par des moyens souvent très
différent depuis le territoire kosovar
l'exode a repris ce matin en poste
frontière de blatche et après une
semaine d'interruption 800 nouveaux
réfugiés de la ville durant ses matches
au sud du kosovo
c'est un train serbe qui les a amenés
d'écart macédonien les transfère
immédiatement vers le camp des stands
kovats tenus par les français le plan
des routes en état de choc qui ne
comprend pas comment des militaires
peuvent être aussi prévenant
ils ont dressé cent tentes
supplémentaires en prévision de leur
arrivée les soldats savent que le kosovo
n'a pas fini de se vider
parmi ces réfugiés une famille de
kosovars résidant en suisse mais prise
au piège de la guerre il était avec des
couteaux des pistolets tout la maison en
fait c'est quoi à chaque fois qu'ils y
passent grand village chasse les gens si
par table ronde des vins les militaires
français devrait en principe quitter ce
camp qu'ils ont monté avant la fin de la
semaine
pourtant leur présence est plus
indispensable que jamais pour accueillir
les passagers de ces trains de l'exil
setola demis ont commencé à arriver les
personnels civils
avec les pistolets comme ça à plat ils
sont commencé les policiers il était
parce que là ils sont vraiment la
lingette que pense avoir acquis alors ce
qui vous ont poussé à prendre le train
pour la non vous qu'allez vous lui
pourquoi la ville durant ces matches est
l'une des cibles des frappes de l'otan
excitant la haine des nationalistes
serbes
avant-hier
dix soldats sont venus dans ma maison
ils sont entrés ma soeur m'a dit de
partir
je me suis enfui
je n'osais pas leur faire face s'il
m'avait trouvé il m'aurait battu plus
tôt vers 12h30
nous avions vu trois soldats battre deux
hommes ma femme m'a dit qu'un soldat
avait essayé de l'emmener
ils lui ont dit qu'ils reviendraient
l'apprendre le lendemain à 9h on n'a pas
osé attendre
800 réfugiés de plus qui bascule dans la
précarité des camps avec encore la peur
aux tripes et l' angoisse pour les
membres de leur famille ils sont restés
là bas
jérôme baugnies on affirme ce soir qu'
un nouvel exode s'annonce que l'action
des services ainsi gilles et le kosovo
pour mieux affronter loup checa avez
vous des informations autant que faire
se peut sur sur ceux sur cela oui claude
les informations que je peux vous donner
c'est celle qui concerne ce secteur
c'était moi que nous avons vu cet
après-midi viennent tous un secteur
frontalier qui va jusqu'à à peu près 30
km d'ici et en plus il ya bien sûr ici
dans ces camps tous ceux qui viennent de
christina par train mais dans ce secteur
qui va jusqu'à 30 km d'ici d'après ces
témoignages effectivement une forte
activité militaire c'est un secteur qui
longe la route entre la macédoine et
pristina et iliad apprécié témoignage de
très nombreux chars serbe
on nous a parlé de 40 chars dans le même
village près de ses vaches
alors évidemment c'est un serbe ont
tendance à faire du kosovo un champ de
bataille sont sous le feu des frappes de
l'otan et qui considèrent tous les
albanais comme des complices de ceux qui
les agressent et il mène une guerre à
outrance en ce moment à lui ses cadences
et le dire bien sûr les applis que saleh
ce principe dont on parle dans la
guérilla maoïste que la guérilla et dans
la population comme un poisson dans
l'eau
eh bien ils essaient de jd l'eau du
poisson et ils font évacuer les
populations civiles d'un certain nombre
de secteurs où les ont décidés de
d'attaqué en force lui ces cas mais dans
les secteurs dont nous avons reçu les
témoignages près d'ici les villageois
nous parler de village où il n'y avait
pas de combattants de la guérilla dont
il ya aussi une volonté effectivement de
vider le pays
en tout cas bien sûr ici toutes les
inquiétudes vont à ceux de leurs amis et
à leurs cousins à toute leur famille qui
sont encore de l'autre côté et si dans
tous les cas qui sont à peu près la
moitié de la population des albanais du
kosovo à peu près 900 milles dont une
grande partie sans doute plus de la
moitié sont déplacés dans les montagnes
et dans tous sans exception en tout cas
tous ces civils veulent absolument
quitter le kosovo en guerre aujourd'hui
merci jérôme en albanie les nouveaux
arrivants sont immédiatement dirigés
vers des camps 5000 kosovars ont pénétré
en albanie
par le poste frontière de maureen à
honor la nuit dernière plusieurs
milliers d'autres pourraient suivre pour
gérer la sécurité de ces camps des
gendarmes français encadrent des
homologues albanais comme l'ont constaté
anne ponsinet et philippe jasselin ils
sont encore cinq mille à être arrivé
depuis s'est tenue trois semaines
conquête petite ville de 2000 habitants
a vu passer des centaines de milliers de
réfugiés
un casse tête pour la police locale qui
fait façon maintenant ses hommes 12 à 15
heures sur le terrain tous les jours
rené carletto et gendarmes français
il fait partie d'une mission
internationale qui depuis deux ans
forment et conseillent les policiers
albanais
face à l'urgence il est monté de tirana
avec quatre collègues slovène turc
hollandais portugais pour aider les
forces de l'ordre locales dans cette
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle
soyons honnêtes ils ont ici un
déferlement de population si on avait la
même chose chez nous même étant bien
mieux organisés y en beaucoup plus de
moyens que ce qu'ils n'ont eux je pense
que nous aurions quelques flottements
aussi un des objectifs de la mission est
aussi de faire le lien entre la police
locale et les organisations humanitaires
pour coordonner le recueil de
témoignages sur les exactions commises
au kosovo aujourd'hui cet homme est
arrivé le coeur brisé sa femme de 23 ans
n'a pas terminé le voyage aller puis
elle est morte terme jacobins à quelques
kilomètres de la frontière
seuls les réservistes et sert aux tempes
et de prendre ma femme par la force
ils ont demandé quel descendre du
tracteur voit qu'elle est descendue
un des soldats voulait la laisser partir
l'autre a refusé la tuer en lui tirant
dessus à l'armé automatique viennent
mais comment prendre en compte tant de
détresse lorsqu'il faut aussi s'occuper
de la circulation et des quelques
escrocs qui profitent de la situation
le tout avec une police qui manque d
équipements de base
historia de police une cinquantaine de
personnes ne disposent que d'une voiture
il est évident que dans de telles
conditions l'exécution des missions s'en
ressent
la mission des policiers et gendarmes
internationaux comprend une aide
matérielle et elle consiste surtout en
conseil et formation
un travail de fond qui n'est pas destiné
à faire face à l'urgence
selon diverses informations venus
d'albanie les forces militaires serbes
auraient pénétré en territoire albanais
au nord à kameni chase aurait attaqué ce
village en fin d'après midi
l'otan n'a pas confirmé et belgrade a
démenti au 20e jour du conflit engagé
par les 19 pays membres de l'otan la
rencontre organisée aujourd'hui en
norvège à oslo entre le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe monsieur
ivanoff et la secrétaire d'état des
états unis madame madeleine albright
market une reprise de l'action
diplomatique
l'entretien était plus long que prévu et
monsieur ivanoff l'a qualifiée de très
utiles
compte-rendu patrice romdhane avec
emmanuel bec réchauffer l'atmosphère
faire fondre la glace et cetera et
cetera quelques métaphores facile et
néanmoins climatiques viennent à
l'esprit quand igor ivanov pose le pied
sur la terre leur viennent il est vrai
que les états unis et la russie sont en
froid depuis le déclenchement de
l'opération force déterminer sous son
capuchon noir madeleine albright précède
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères de quelques minutes
tous deux se retrouvent à quelques
encablures dans un hôtel transformé en
camp retranché pour cause de rencontre
au sommet à 10h poignée de main pour la
photo ensuite trois heures d'entretiens
dont washington et moscou sont informés
en permanence nous fait-on savoir enfin
ils réapparaîtront pour médiatiser leur
désaccord sur le déploiement d'une force
internationale de paix au kosovo
c'est la question la plus compliquée
confessera igor ivanov qui rappelle
qu'une telle force nécessite l'agrément
de la yougoslavie
mais au nom de l'otan madeleine albright
campe sur ses positions
la question de la force internationale
est la question la plus difficile dira
madeleine albright
nous sommes globalement d'accord pour
dire que cette force est nécessaire pour
que le retour des réfugiés s'effectue
dans la confiance et la sécurité
mais ce sur quoi nous divergeons c'est
sur sa composition
l'otan doit être au coeur de cette force
fin de la rencontre en partant igor
ivanov flash un commentaire nous avons
fait un petit pas mais sans doute pas
aussi important que nous le souhaitions
la patrie someday nos bilan de cette
journée à oslo la réintégration de la
russie effectivement claude je crois
qu'on peut résumer la réunion d'oslo
d'une phrase ou d'une boutade c'est un
petit pas pour le kosovo car au fond
rien n'est réglé et un grand pas pour la
russie un grand pas pour la russie car
elles se retrouvent sur la même estrade
diplomatique que les états unis elle
parle directement elles traitent d'égal
à égal avec les américains dans une de
ses mises en scène qui lui rappelle sans
doute son heure de gloire ce qui est
assez amusant c'était de voir comment
monsieur ivanoff dès le début de la
conférence de presse c'est lui qui a
pris la parole en premier
cet employé a expliqué qu'il avait été
certes question du kosovo avec madeleine
albright mais aussi d'autres dossiers le
dossier irakien le processus de paix au
proche orient ou encore le dossier du
désarmement qu'un peu comme s'il faisait
un large tour d'horizon comme au bon
vieux temps j'allais dire celui de la
guerre froide maintenant pour en revenir
au conflit du kosovo reste à savoir ce
que moscou est prêt à faire concrètement
sur le plan diplomatique auprès de
belgrade pour que cesse la guerre
y aura-t-il une nouvelle mission
primakov une mission ivanoff à belgrade
pour tenter de convaincre ce modèle
milosevic pour l'instant rien n'est
prévu même si monsieur ivanov a dit
qu'il était prêt à faire le voyage de
belgrade
quant à savoir si les américains ont
demandé aux russes d'aller à belgrade et
bien la réponse nous est venue franche
claire et directe de la bouche de madame
albright elle a dit tout simplement nous
n'avons rien demandé aux russes
merci patrice alors vu de moscou gilles
rabin qui a le plus lâcher les
américains ou les russes écoutez dans
l'apparence que madeleine albright et
igor ivanov ont voulu venez en commun
dans l'apparence officiel chacun a fait
un bout du chemin
mais dans la réalité concrète igor
ivanov le ministre russe a accepté
quatre des cinq conditions posées par
l'otan pour un arrêt des frappes sur la
yougoslavie et sur la cinquième position
comme le disait patrice romedenne le
point principal sur le déploiement d'une
force de sécurité au kosovo
même si les russes et les américains ont
constaté leur désaccord sur la nature la
composition et le commandement de cette
force moscou aujourd'hui on reconnaît là
l'absolue nécessité c'est un grand pas
en tout cas vu de moscou
même si boscou rappelle encore que
l'accord préalable de belgrade est
nécessaire alors compte tenu du rapport
de force de politique intérieure à
moscou c'est à dire la présence massive
des députés communistes
quelle est la réaction de politique ce
soir côté ya pas encore de réaction peut
officielle des oppositions communiste
nationaliste à cause du décalage horaire
et aussi peut-être parce qu'il se donne
le temps de la réflexion
mais on peut penser que la réunion
d'oslo malgré son peu de résultats ne
constituera pas ne constituera ni une
bonne nouvelle ni un progrès pour ces
oppositions
tout simplement parce que vu de belgrade
leurs alliés communistes et
nationalistes serbes se sentent un peu
plus isolé ce soir d'une part parce que
jamais le soutien de la russie à la
serbie n'a été aussi conditionnel et
d'autre part parce qu'une toute petite
porte s'est entrouverte aujourd'hui à
oslo petite porte qui peut se refermer
très vite demain sur l'éventualité de
voir imposer un jour à belgrade
la présence d'une force internationale
de sécurité et sur son corollaire c'est
à dire la mise sous administration
provisoire international de la province
du kosovo
merci gilles un convoi d aide
humanitaire russe est entré ce matin en
yougoslavie il avait été bloqué par les
autorités hongroises
ce premier convoi fait partie d'une aide
humanitaire russe et bélarusse de 900
tonnes de colis alimentaires de
vêtements ainsi que de médicaments
à washington le président clinton vient
d'annoncer qu'il fallait passer
maintenant à l'étape suivante pour la
campagne aérienne des forces alliées il
a demandé au congrès une aide budgétaire
urgentes et immédiates mais pendant que
l'on discutait oslo l'aviation de l'otan
ont renouvelé ses raids contre des
cibles à belgrade mais aussi à pristina
les destructions sont très importantes
la télévision serbe a longuement montrer
la conséquence dramatique des missiles
de l'otan qui ont frappé un train sur un
ton hier commentaires françois corner
c'était le train 393 des chemins de fer
yougoslavie d'effectuer la liaison entre
belgrade et ris tomates au sud est du
pays
peu avant 10 heures du matin hier le
congrès est arrêté à la proche d'un pont
quand deux avions de l'otan tir de
missile l'un sur le pont l'autre sur le
train qui s'embrase aussitôt 10 morts et
16 blessés seront retirés de ces wagons
calcinés
l'état major de l'otan a précisé que ses
pilotes n'avaient pas l'intention de
toucher le train mais seulement le pont
cette ligne ferroviaire étant utilisée
pour l'approvisionnement des forces
serbes au kosovo avec cette animation à
l'appui la télévision serbe internet pas
les faits de la même façon les deux
s'amusaient directement de trains dit
elle ce n'est pas une bavure mais une
agression délibérée contre le peuple
serbe
la nuit dernière un nouveau raid aérien
a été mené contre ce même pont
ferroviaire qui étaient détruits annonce
l'otan mais la télévision de belgrade
aujourd'hui ne nous le montre pas prise
pour cible également et pour la deuxième
fois en une semaine
cette raffinerie de pancevo près de
belgrade avec la destruction totale de 7
autres raffineries de novi sad après un
troisième raid la nuit dernière l'otan
estime que l'armée serbe qui auraient
déjà perdu 50 à 70% de ses stocks de
carburant sera maintenant totalement
privé de ses approvisionnements belgrade
rétorque que ces troupes disposent de
suffisamment de carburant pour résister
encore six mois aux alliés guerre des
chiffres
guerre des ondes pour enrayer dit l'otan
la propagande serbe depuis hier soir les
émetteurs et les relais de télévision
comme celui ci au sud de belgrade ont
été pris pour cible par les avions de
l'otan
pendant ce temps le président yougoslave
qui recevait aujourd'hui à belgrade une
délégation de jeunes politiciens grecs
déclarait que la politique de la force
n'avait pas je cite de perspectives
l'opération de l'otan qualifiés d'
humanitaires et baptisé abri alliés est
en cours en albanie la france a déployé
700 hommes blonde va envoyer 1800 hommes
supplémentaires en macédoine mais aussi
en grèce et cette future forces militaro
humanitaire comment faut-il l'appelait
doit gérer au mieux la situation et la
sécurité des réfugiés et l'aide
humanitaire internationale qu'ils
reçoivent
reportage bertrand
oc et roger motte il pleut et les
cavaliers du premier hussards
parachutistes découvre l'albanie il
pleut et sur l'aéroport de tirana les
places sont chères
dernier arrivé dans le dispositif
militaro humanitaire français les bérets
rouges ont passé la journée à se
bricoler un campement en bordure de
tarbes n'est pas confortable mais un peu
de temps aux organisations auprès de ce
système mais comme on veut
vous savez déjà quand et où on va
commencer à vous utilisez dès demain en
fait dans avec les hélicoptères en
protection des zones au bout
effectivement ils posent ils échangent
leur matériel
en attendant on piétine
on frise parfois l'encombrement
hélicoptères français et américains
voisine sans se mélanger concurrents
plus que partenaire à défaut d'un
commandement commun c'est chacun pour
soi et l'humanitaire peu plus
on travaille côte-à-côte pas encore
ensemble si ce n'est que pour les
questions de sécurité dans tout ce qui
est trafic aérien circulation aérienne
effectivement la coopération est
beaucoup plus grave mais les américains
se taillent la part du lion
plus de moyens plus de matériel plus de
personnes déjà presque chez ouvre
surtout depuis que l'albanie acedera
l'otan la souveraineté de son espace et
les américains sont déjà 500 ici bientôt
ils seront deux mille cinq cents c'est
beaucoup pour faire de l'humanitaire
mais c'est précisément le personnel
nécessaire à l'entretien au maniement et
à la sécurisation
les hélicoptères de combat apache qui
sont attendus ici en albanie dans les
semaines à venir en france à l'assemblée
nationale la séance des questions au
gouvernement était entièrement consacrée
au kosovo cet après midi chaque groupe
parlementaire a exprimé son analyse est
le premier ministre a répondu
globalement monsieur jospin a manifesté
de très vives inquiétudes pour les
populations restées au kosovo est
qualifiée l'objectif d'un kosovo en paix
comme un impératif démocratique
reportage jean baptiste préavis et
christophe vignal dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée
on croise des groupes de visiteurs
inattendus en principe les députés sont
en vacances aujourd'hui pourtant ils
sont exceptionnellement revenu au palais
bourbon dans l'hémicycle un seul sujet
le kosovo c'est pour le neige ce pas il
s'agissait d'expliquer à nouveau
d'informer et de mettre d'abord en avant
l'évolution diplomatique de la situation
la marque
l'organisation des nations unies et en
particulier le conseil de sécurité
doivent jouer tout leur rôle dans la
définition d'un règlement politique au
kosovo et dans sa mise en oeuvre
une mise en oeuvre dans laquelle l'union
européenne doit prendre toutes ses
responsabilités alors l'onu et évoquer
les communistes sont satisfaits lionel
jospin a pourtant rappelé la
détermination française dans les
opérations militaires au pc on ne veut
retenir que le recours à la diplomatie
quand j'entends donc effectivement le
premier ministre privilégier ce choix je
souhaite vraiment que l'on puisse
avancer et ça va à mon avis dans un sens
qui est celui qu on préconisait pour le
reste c'est la quasi unanimité de la
gauche à la droite
l'unité de vues entre le président de la
république et le premier ministre y est
pour beaucoup
me réjouis d'une manière générale dans
cette affaire et dans la gestion de
cette affaire la france parle d'une
seule voix
en fait dans les couloirs les seule
nuance portait sur les priorités
bien sûr il faut trouver une solution
politique à ce conflit
mais il faut aussi surtout être au
rendez-vous de l'urgence humanitaire du
drame physiques et psychologiques qui
frappe les réfugiés c'est qui est la
priorité des priorités c'est d'assurer
la protection du peuple kosovar et donc
de se décider à envoyer une force
d'interposition
l'explication gouvernementale s'est
poursuivie dans la soirée à la
commission des affaires étrangères
c'est peut-être un signe à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui on a surtout parlé de
diplôme ès pour accueillir des réfugiés
du kosovo le numéro de téléphone mis en
place par le secrétariat d'état à la
santé a reçu 400 mille appels depuis
jeudi dernier numéro avait été
communiquée ici même par lionel jospin
les voici
il concerne d'abord l'envoi de colis et
puis l'accueil des réfugiés
je vous laisse le temps de pouvoir les
noter aujourd'hui les premiers réfugiés
du kosovo sont arrivés à paris grâce à
la croix rouge et à france terre d'asile
ils recevront un visa de séjour leur
permettant éventuellement de travailler
reportage
elsa marc goût et eric de l'agneau sur
des visages fatigués car leur périple à
travers l'europe touche à sa fin ils
sont 24
quelques familles et beaucoup
d'adolescents partie du kosovo il ya une
semaine ils ont voyagé avec des moyens
de fortune certains en tracteur d'autres
à pied pour rejoindre l'albanie de là
ils ont gagné l'italie par bateau puis
la france un voyage qui leur a coûté
parfois plus de dix mille francs pour
payer les passeurs hébergés dans un
premier temps au centre d'accueil pour
demandeurs d'asile de créteil beaucoup
cependant vont tenter dans les prochains
jours
rejoindre leurs familles dispersées à
travers l'europe a priori est ce qu il
en est certains d'entre vous qui veulent
partir vers un autre pays dans les jours
prochains
d'accord et vous en angleterre le
premier repas chaud depuis 24 heures
tous racontent la même et triste
histoire comme petric qui vient de jaco
va au kosovo après les bombardements
les serbes nous ont obligés à quitter le
pays ils nous ont dit allez donc vous
faire protéger par le temps les chars
serbes ont tout détruit toutes les
maisons à christina et dans les environs
raconte cet homme qui dit même avoir vu
les serbes se fusiller des kosovars
l'état a promis d'accorder un titre de
séjour d'un an aux réfugiés qui
souhaitent rester en france une
procédure administrative simplifiée les
dispensera de visa d'autres réfugiés
vont sans doute arriver dans les
prochains jours mais cette fois c'est
l'état français qui prendra en charge
leur transport
quant à la solidarité manifestée par les
français sous forme de dons d'argent de
colis elle a presque submergé plusieurs
organisations humanitaires faut
maintenant gérer les stocks et mettre en
place une logistique complexe pour
envoyer au plus vite des biens
alimentaires des vêtements et des
médicaments collectés par centaines de
tonnes
explication diego garcia avec avait
pozzo et puis en région
éric perrin et philippe du mail pas de
répit pour les 60 bénévoles chargés du
tri et du conditionnement dans les 1200
comités locaux de la croix-rouge en
france comme ici à bordeaux la plus des
denrées alimentaires a surpris tout le
monde
depuis quelques jours 80 tonnes de
nourriture sont arrivés ici il ya des
gens qui donnent trois verres donner du
concret parce que je crois que s'ils
sont sûrs que ça arrivera l'avant dans
ce hangar parisien
même effervescence qu'à bordeaux en
france
la croix rouge a collecté plus de 8000
tonnes de denrées alimentaires
un stock énorme qui aurait pu engendrer
de gros problèmes de logistique et de
transport des difficultés qui ne semble
pas insurmontable pour les responsables
de l'opération
j'ai absolument pas débordés par
l'afflux de denrées alimentaires qui a
été nous arrive tous les jours
la croix rouge a mis en place une de
tels moyens logistiques aussi de tels
moyens sur un plan humain en termes de
recrutement tous les bénévoles ont bien
répondu
on tourne à 40 personnes à peu près par
jour en plus comme vous pouvez le
constater on a un camion qui est prêt à
partir pour marseille chargés de 20
tonnes de denrées alimentaires
ce camion privé est le premier à partir
mais la plus grande partie de la
collecte sera acheminée par la poste la
poste qui affrète à partir d'aujourd'hui
50 à 60 camions par jour soit 1800
tonnes transportées quotidiennement
l'opération devrait coûter au total 10
millions de francs à la croix-rouge qui
a reçu 30 millions de francs de dons en
argent pour les responsables de
l'association
une collecte alimentaire se justifie
pleinement n'est pas une mauvaise idée
et c'était même une idée qui nous séduit
encore que ce nous demandons aujourd'hui
de passer
autre type d' aides directes ce sont les
kits hygiène des produits d'hygiène nous
souhaitons que les français nous donne
aujourd'hui des produits de ce type car
nous craignons les première épidémie
dans les camps tous les colis
alimentaires seront rapidement
centralisés dans ses entrepôts à
marseille les deux premier avion chargé
de 40 tonnes de nourriture décolleront
jeudi de la base militaire d'istres le
reste de l'aide sera acheminée par
bateau le plus rapidement possible et
puis hélas il faut signaler quelques
tentatives d'escroquerie à la solidarité
attention donc aux collecte au porte à
porte la croix rouge n'organise pas ce
type de collecte les tentatives
malfaisante ont été constatés dans la
région de bordeaux c'est ce que vient de
nous dire notre correspondant éric
perrin la situation au kosovo les
frappes de l'otan l'histoire qui a
souvent rapproché les serbes les
français voilà de quoi alimenter les
discussions d'intellectuels d'écrivains
d'origine yougoslave vivent depuis très
longtemps un pari daniel wolfromm et
rémy poissonnier ont rencontré deux
écrivains depuis toujours opposée au
régime de slobodan milosevic
mais qui ne comprennent pas le rôle de
la france dans le temps la librairie de
l'âge d'homme un des plus grands
éditeurs de littérature slave en europe
mobilisation pour la cause serbe
rencontre avec deux écrivains l'un est
autodidacte il fit à montmartre mais il
est né près de belgrade
l'autre à sa gauche vit lui aussi à
paris depuis 40 ans si différents que
puissent être ses deux hommes ils se
retrouvent sur un point leur histoire le
serbe avait une splendide civilisation
moyen âge là
lafleur les témoignages de cette
civilisation c'est roux ici dans ses
livres et ses n'est que la partie de la
civilisation aider les délestages serbes
au kosovo ne vous avait pas quelque
chose de plus moderne montrer mais ces
saumons racines c'est comme si ur et non
scié aucun fédéral gothique
c'est la partie essentielle de notre
héritage être serbe
c'est ce pouvoir se reconnaître dans sa
foi dont ses origines ses titres
je dirais même limite c'est une vieille
habitude qu'ont appris et on a hérité de
ses parents
après cette évocation d'un passé
nostalgique il passe à la culture
française là se révèle ce qu'ils ont sur
le coeur
nous sommes nourris de la culture
française et pour danser manou en france
mais en serbie il ya des millions de
gens pour lesquels la france
s'identifier à l'idée de la justice et
pour nous c'est inconcevable que la
france a pu basculer dans l'app livrant
des affiches injustice c'est à dire dans
cette coalition contre notre peuple
la france contre la serbie c'est quelque
chose contre nature la discussion
reprend sans fin défile le passé des uns
et des autres il est vrai que pour ces
intellectuels serbe
l'avenir est devenu bien difficile à
imaginer
voilà pour l'actualité au kosovo
actualité que le président république
monsieur jacques chirac a évidemment
évoqué en recevant en fin d'après midi
monsieur romano prodi
l'ancien président du conseil italien a
été choisi par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens peut présider la
commission européenne à la place de
jacques santer cet entretien a lieu à la
veille du conseil européen qui se
tiendra donc demain à bruce jeudi les
algériens sont appelés à choisir un
président de la république le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle voit
s'affronter sept candidats pour succéder
au président liamine zeroual
bien sûr le terrorisme la violence sont
au coeur des préoccupations des femmes
et des hommes en algérie mais il ne faut
cependant pas oublier un état des lieux
économique et sociale plutôt déficient
ainsi l'exemple du logement obsession
majeur des familles et des jeunes
les logements neufs sont rares les
immeubles d'habitation ont besoin de
rénovations très importante dans la
banlieue d'alger pour se loger c'est
l'anarchie et cela participe au climat
de violence sociale
reportage thierry thulliez et bruno
girodon
on est à la carrière jaubert si un
ensemble de logements qui a été
construit en 58 assez rapidement il a dû
être construire en une année est en fait
traiter de logements qui étaient faits
pour résorber les bidonvilles qui
étaient là quarante ans plus tard ce qui
devait être une cité transit voué à une
destruction rapide est toujours debout
800 logements où s'entassent près de
cinq mille locataires en moyenne six ou
sept personnes par appartement brahim
était encore un enfant quand avec ses
parents il a emménagé dans une pièce de
6 mètres carrés dans une maison depuis
62 à cette personne l'indépendance
l'état algérien s'était engagé à reloger
les familles
rien n'est venu alors brahim a dû
improviser en s'appropriant les
sanitaires collectifs et sidérale pour
les gens
moi j'ai eu qu'à fils j'ai cassé pour
moi et pour ma femme et mes enfants
le voisin a eu plus de chance il a
récupéré un appartement supplémentaires
dans son deux-pièces vif 14 personnes
trop pauvres pour se loger ailleurs il
compte sur l'aide de l'état
nous avons mis quoi
nous attendons des logements et vous
savez pourquoi j'en avais tu le sais pas
trop la pression démographique est venu
aggraver l'absence de politique de
logement la natalité galopante a
transformé le visage d'alger dans
l'anarchie d'immenses banlieue ont
poussé gagner sur la grand' paille elles
sont vite devenus des ghettos pour
l'architecte qui nous guide jusqu'à
badjarah le terrain était fertile là
pour les groupes armés qui ont pu
recruter parmi une jeunesse désoeuvrée
les gens sont complètement exclu de la
vie urbaine est en fait quelqu'un qui
veut aller au cinéma s'acheter des
fringues aller se promener
il est obligé d'aller au centre d'alger
kita qui est à une heure de transport
rue doit finalement il n'y va pas il est
là il contre le mur
au niveau de l'esthétique de la classe
politique des dirigeants mais il n'ya
pas encore cette prise de conscience
qu'en fait faire ce type d'architecturé
sait faire violence aux gens et tant
qu'on n'aura pas compris je ne dis pas
que c'est l'architecturé l'urbanisme qui
déclenche cette violence non ça allait
trop loin mais je pense qu' un germe
abdennour ne manque pas de projets de
réhabilitation mais il n'est pas écouté
la preuve aux portes d'alger d'autres
cités vont bientôt être prise d'assaut
et rien ne semble devoir arrêter cette
énorme machine à fabriquer des laissés
pour compte
publication du premier rapport d'
enquête administrative et technique
après l incendie du tunnel du mont blanc
c'était le 24 mars dernier l' incendie a
fait au moins 41 morts les points
critiques soulevées par le rapport d'
enquête porte sur l'organisation des
secours et la conception de l'ouvragé
commentaires patrick fandio et guillaume
faudra plusieurs fois annoncée plusieurs
fois reporté les premières explications
sur l' incendie du tunnel du mont blanc
ont enfin pu avoir lieu ce matin
minute par minute les experts ont
d'abord reconstituer le film du drame
ces quelques instants qui ont précédé le
gigantesque brasil 10h53 le camion belge
s'arrête et prend feu au garage 21 c'est
bien le poste de commandement français
qui donne l'alerté
c'est encore lui qui ferment l'accès du
tunnel par la france à 10h55
deux minutes plus tard son collègue
italien wind un temps de réaction jugé
satisfaisant par les enquêteurs selon
eux aucun délai anormal n'apparaît dans
la réaction du poste de commandement les
critiques elle s'adresse d'abord aux
systèmes d'extraction des gaz toxiques
sans galerie d'évacuation sans aération
efficace le tunnel est envahi par la
fumée
les secours sont impuissants mal équipés
mal préparés à ce type d'intervention
le dernier exercice de simulation
remonte à dix ans
on peut dire qu'il y a eu ces dernières
années une certaine réticence de la
société française et de la société
italienne aussi à les organiser
on peut penser aussi que les pouvoirs
publics quels qu'ils soient français
italien et la commission
intergouvernementale aurait dû être plus
ferme pour imposer ces exercices
également mis en cause
autoroute et tunnel du mont-blanc
présidée par rémy chardon concernant le
nombre d'usagers prisonniers du tunnel
aucun point précis n'a pu être fournie
par à tmb au moment de la lettre les
disques informatiques n'ont pas pu être
décodé une erreur lourde de conséquences
sur l'organisation des secours
le rapport écarte vite peut être trop
vite la responsabilité du préfet breuil
les pompiers lui avait fait parvenir un
document sur les lacunes du dispositif
de sécurité en cas d'incendié
le préfet n'avait pas donné de suite les
experts ne lui en tiennent pas rigueur
le rapport définitif sera publié le 31
mai prochain
aversa une infirmière de mantes la jolie
mise en examen pour plusieurs homicides
volontaires pour avoir pratiqué des
euthanasies a été écroué la jeune femme
qui était jusqu'à présent sous contrôle
judiciaire a fait l'objet selon le
magistrat instructeur d'une nouvelle
appréciation du dossier
fin de citation des propos du magistrat
instructeur selon une étude du régime
d'assurance chômage unedic plus de deux
jeunes sur trois demandeurs d'emploi
âgés de moins de 25 ans ne bénéficie pas
d'une indemnité de chômage l'étude
précise que les femmes sont plus
nombreuses encore ne pas être indemnisé
voici l'exemple de l'une d'entre elles
âgée de 22 ans qui tente de s'en sortir
se sortir cette mauvaise situation
c'est un châtillon dans le département
des hauts-de-seine reportage emilie
lance en berne à ronfler savoir rédiger
une feuille de paye sur un ordinateur
ce n'est apparemment pas grand chose
mais cette formation permettra peut-être
à les skis de décrocher enfin un emploi
stable
elle qui alterne depuis deux ans petits
boulots et période de chômage sans
aucune indemnité non nerlich le pas
puisque j'ai 22 ans
et puis tout ce que j'ai cotisé pendant
deux ans je ne peux même qu'à avoir même
ce soit même domine francs par an
puisque c'est pas cotisé assez pour
toucher des indemnités de chômage
il faut au moins avoir travaillé quatre
mois sur les huit derniers mois
si les deux tiers des jeunes sans emploi
ne sont pas indemnisés c'est avant tout
parce que beaucoup multiplie les cdd et
les contrats d'intérim et passe donc à
travers les mailles du filet moi je
prends l'exemple de la sécurité sociale
il suffit de cotiser je crois pendant un
mois pour être couvert pendant l'année
donc pourquoi en ce qui concerne les
assedic qui est aussi d'assurance quitte
une assurance chômage
on ne pourrait pas effectivement à
partir du moment où le jeune surtout un
jeune qui enchaîne petits boulots sur
petits boulots partiront ils cotisent
pendant un mois on lui donne un an de
droits
pourtant pour la directrice de la
mission locale le problème est plus
profond
mieux vaudrait selon elle assurer un
meilleur accueil un meilleur suivi de
chaque jeune en difficulté faut pas
parler une icône de critères de durée ou
du temps c'est vraiment de s'occuper de
cas des jeunes mais de façon plus
réfléchie à la rentrée de septembre les
partenaires sociaux qui gèrent l'unedic
décideront de réformer ou non le système
leslie de son côté espère bien voir
trouver un emploi d'ici là le medef le
patronat français préconise un
allongement à 45 années de la durée de
cotisation pour avoir droit à une
retraite complète est le président du
medef monsieur essayèrent a de nouveau
appelé à la création de fonds de pension
pour régler le problème du déficit du
système de retraites
le plan du medef et qualifiée de
provocation par la cgt sports à paris ce
soir et demain sur france 3 puis sur
france 2 demain les épreuves de patinage
les masters de bercy avec un spectacle
inédit celui de surya bonaly c'est elle
et de philippe candeloro
il va suivre l'une empruntera le masque
de zorro
et puis l'autre c'est lui la jupe
écossaise de brefs pertes chercher des
rêves
ouverture ce soir à bourges du 23e
printemps de la chanson jusqu'à dimanche
ce nouveau talent et chanteur largement
confirmés se produiront ce soir
l'ouverture à bourges se fait avec
natacha atlas entre rails et techno
cette chanteuse s'est fort bien mélanger
les genres avec toute la grâce
égyptienne reportage pierre emmanuel
luneau jean-jacques le garrec must
l'egypte éternelle est en train de
changer
depuis quelques mois le pays des
pyramides et le creuset d'un nouveau
genre musical à la fois techno jungle et
chant oriental natacha atlas est une des
premières à avoir osé se mélangent
cet artiste cosmopolite est né en
belgique d'un père juif égyptien et
d'une mère anglaise enfants et duquel
européenne où ses rêves ont toujours été
tourné vers l'orient c'est des pâtes des
choses comme ça et des sculptures
quelques années plus tard c'est en
découvrant de vieilles comédies
égyptienne qu'elle décide à son tour de
devenir chanteuse
aujourd'hui la musicienne aux semelles
de vent a décidé de livres au caire
comme une femme indépendante et moderne
oui 15 15 ans ça ne change pas c'est
toujours la même mélodie
même chose quoi alors on essaye de
mettre quelque chose de nouveau
enfin son nouveau comme cette adaptation
d'une chanson de françoise hardy
je
vous êtes
team aaa
en mini du caire de londres natacha
atlas qu'une ses racines il venir ni
aucune escale hâtives
cette dualité anglo arabe je crois que
je n'en aurai jamais assez il vient ici
pour enrichir malaisie mais au contact
de mes amis et tous m'aide à élever mona
et puis quand je rentre en angleterre je
prends d'autres influences et je fais
d'autres échanges
affranchi de tous les préjugés quand
européen qu'egyptien natacha atlas créer
sa musique celle d'une artiste libre
voilà avant de refermer ce journal je
vous rappel concernant l'actualité au
kosovo la rencontre diplomatique c'était
à oslo en norvège dans l'âme albright
américaine monsieur ivanov fleurus seul
différend une porte sur la force
internationale qui pourraient être
déployés concernant les réfugiés
continuent d'affluer en macédoine et en
albanie on voit ces chiffres augmenter
chaque jour tandis que l'armée sert
continue son avancée son nettoyage de
village en serbie et puis le président
clinton vient d'annoncer qu'il y aurait
de nouvelles demandes budgétaires tandis
que monsieur jocelyn a confirmé
l'engagement de la france et s'est
montré très inquiet de la situation
intérieure au kosovo d'autre part le
général wesley clark de l'otan a fait
part d'une demande de 300 avions
supplémentaires
et puis concernant le mont blanc après
l'accident d'utilisation blanc le 24
mars à mai qui a fait au moins 41 morts
un rapport qui met en cause la
conception des ouvrages et
l'organisation des secours
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
nathalie rihouet à 20h55 l'étudiante un
film de claude pinoteau avec sophie
marceau et vincent lindon à 22h55 la vie
à l'endroit d'un magazine de mireille
dumas vous fera faire un voyage plutôt
insolite à l'aéroport de roissy le
dernier journal vous sera présenté par
florence duprat à zéro heure 40 suivie
du cercle de philippe lefait demain vous
retrouverez à 13h rachid arhab à demain
20h bonsoir
autre